and i hope this helps as you lay your
head on your pillow put the phone next
to your ear
sleep sleep my baby
feverish baby
sleep my baby
i love you
[Music]
take your medicine
drink the cough
syrup sleep sleep my baby
i love you
[Music]
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buddies it's a taste buds show i'm
joe derosa that's a volcano here there
you go do we need a flashier intro like
because i know like on hey babe you guys
sing every week
wanna put taste buds into a song no i
mean i don't want to just copy you know
i don't want to copy what you guys do
well it's i'm not copying if i if i do
it myself i'm just doing it more
copying myself i always feel like this
should be how we start ready t a s t
you want us to start that way yeah
that's your alternative to what i just
said so how does it go
like this ready there you go hiya tastes
buddies welcome to ttas
[Laughter]
i initially didn't like it whatsoever
and now all of a sudden i'm like oh that
could be fun i like it yeah it's great
it's a bit militant
it feels like sports like you know yeah
well i feel like this is like a battle
yeah
you know speaking of sports we watched
the jake paul fight last night yeah i
mean whoever thought you'd say those
words it's a weird sentence to say right
but he's just they know how to promote a
fight they know how to spark interest
that's for damn sure but also too like
it's like he's like officially a boxer
you don't even suppose i mean yeah i
guess right i mean
he hasn't boxed a boxer yet
another
straight-up traditional boxer but
uh the uh the match-ups well now the at
least the last two ones with ben askren
and tyron woodley have been very
intriguing
for multiple reasons
but i was watching
the match with you
and as i was watching it and i would
watch so many
of the undercard fights and the title
belt go to decision
i saw in play statistics
determining
whether or not a man won a battle
or not
and it made me think of
our chart right okay you want to go you
want to hearken back to that no i'm just
saying i just it would have been a great
example to use in the argument for the
statistical win yeah but a copy stat a
stat line in box i mean you need it
you need it in boxing right yeah but but
for a boxer's ranking they go by their
record
for a fight they go by this the stat
line that's right but for their overall
record they're not like well out of your
50 fights how many rights have you
landed and how many rights have you
thrown you are right but how many fights
do they win oh yeah i see what you're
saying okay yeah you're right all right
i'm with you yeah i'm with you i'm dense
but i got it i think um
here's another thing i wanted to bring
up
before we get into this please bring out
whatever you like at any time thank you
i appreciate it so this is the forum for
it yeah
uh
i
i'm not kidding
i saw it in front of me last week when
we recorded okay our last episode when
we recorded
and it still didn't register
i thought it was this whole time i
thought it was annie ann's
pretzels auntie anne's no i thought it
was annie
anne's oh like annie anne's like the
same name twice
you didn't know
that the thing was based on ant and no
oh but you've seen with your eyeballs in
a mole any ends
no in my head it's always when i saw you
type it out yeah in the post
i was like why did you not bring it up
then oh this is what it was
we have a document in our phones
that has the statistics shared document
yeah share doc and i don't share docs
with many men
you gotta you really gotta know where
they've come from uh but we have a doc a
shared dock app that has all of our
episodes and battles listed so we can
keep track and when i saw it last week
on monday when the episode went up or
was it uh it was today actually with the
day of this recording when the episode
went up
i went into the dock and i saw
auntie anne's and i was like oh he
spelled it wrong he thinks it's anti and
then i was like wait a minute is it
auntie
yeah and then i went and looked online
on twitter and i was like oh my god it's
auntie anne's i thought it was annie
we didn't make a joke about that
when i said it just now you didn't even
hear that i said it wrong i know i
thought it was annie because you could
say yeah
yeah yeah because you can't you can't
distinguish it yeah yeah
well you got scorched
are you embarrassed about it or am i
embarrassed no because scale of one to
ten who followed me today cinnabon
and they direct message me
i'm sorry they messaged they they
commented to me and they said we know
who the real champion is and we follow
each other now
did annie ann's follow you
they didn't uh annie hands i took you to
victory and i got nothing radio silence
from you and i will tell you right now i
will jump ship to the cinnabon to the ss
cinnabon
immediately if i do not hear any anne's
you have till the end of the day i was
on the i was like you say it like like a
batman villain
that's not even my word let's not even
get cute and and
you got to you got to the end of the day
yeah by the way i went on cinnabon's
twitter feed
they announced that cinnabon mini bond
cookies are back
and they're chocolate chip cookies
i mean you want to go
on chocolate chip cookies
and you want to go futz around with
pretzels sounds gross and delicious at
the same time i wonder if i think
they're just chocolate chip cookies oh
oh i told you they were like cinnamon
roll chocolate chips too much chunky
chocolate chip cookies i will say you
think that cinnabon you think that the
well do you think that it got to the
cinnabon brass or do you think that's
just the social media cinnabon that
found that that followed you that's
brass enough for me that's brass and i
mean my foot's in the door do you think
that they watched that means that they
did they watched the whole episode you
think they just watched here's the thing
most likely they just watched the clip
that went up but i shall tell you you
never know with a company like that
that's probably intriguing and they
probably went ahead and watched the
whole thing i don't know
in what ways i slandered cinnabon but i
wonder if now they have a personal
grudge against me or they understand
this is all in this spirit of
competition i hope they do i mean you
really ran your mouth about them and i
got to be honest with you i don't think
they watch the whole thing because they
didn't mention any of your negative
comments and they also didn't bring up
that i said a cinnamon is the thing you
eat before you rob a gamestop
well that was in the clip
yeah oh yeah it was yeah
they didn't care get them on you're all
right
[Laughter]
have one's all right you know you want
to send a bunch of free cinnamons they
change the tide of the
relationship together send the cinnabon
jackie fabulous chimed in too our friend
jackie fabulous great comic very funny
she chimed in and she said jj fab yeah
she said i love these battles and she
goes i hate when i smell the cinnabon
because now now i know i have to get one
something i'm paraphrasing yeah but she
uh she jumped in on my team thank thank
you jackie
uh
but uh people really uh reacted to this
cinnabon already today i mean i'm saying
it like a week ago it's it's it's
happening as we speak
what's what was the uh
percentage breakdown do you remember
it was pretty heavy the loser was in the
30s oh so it was a it was a pretty
decisive it was heavy for pretz yeah
yeah but i mean
oddly enough pretzels took me down in
the pretzel chip battle
i rep pretzels
i read pretzels and i lost big time but
then when i went to soft baked pretzels
so pretzels have
kind of like kind of uh
made up for it i got to tell you i'm i'm
from philadelphia as you know and
philadelphia is the home of the soft
pretzel i love soft pretzels what annie
anne's does is technically a soft
pretzel
but they are not
traditional soft pretzels like i don't
mean because of the flavor i mean
because of the way it's shaped there's
not a big meaty part in the middle
yeah i don't know it just it lacks some
of the substance that a soft pretzel
from philly really has question about
philly because when you were like i'm
from philly i was like joe's derose is
from philadelphia born and raised so uh
uh in west where where's west
philadelphia in relation to people were
raised it was on the playground no no
joking yeah good good
i don't i did a joke one time
forget it i'm not gonna be able to
remember at all so what's your question
the the song westfield one of my
patreons most of my days chilling out
maxing relaxing all cool and all
shooting some b-ball outside out of
school when a couple of guys that were
no good started making trouble in my
neighborhood i got in one little fight
my mom got scared she said you're moving
with your auntie and i want my pillow
where you just put it the audacity you
can put whatever you want just talk
just tuck the sleeve just tuck the
corners in i mean you literally tucked
it in pulled it off my lap and put it
where you wanted it
just as long as it's tucked babe wait so
so
it that it's the most psychotic thing i
would say for a cab and when it came
here the license plate said freshen that
dice in the mirror if anything i could
say this cab was where then don't forget
your homes to bel-air i pulled up to the
house around seven or eight okay so i
was in a i was in an interview one time
and i started to answer the questions
that were being asked of me with sound
bites from
bel-air but i didn't like cue that cue
them in i don't think and they were like
so you know what i was like oh you know
i was born you know with philadelphia
west side you know i wasn't giving it
exactly right and then the
the guy picked up on a little bit and
they said um
uh and then he started following along
with me
might have been me and casey doing a bit
and then he goes you know what time were
you uh did you get to the house i said
about
i said i got there about 7 30.
because he says i pulled up to the house
around i said 7 30. it was a real hood
when it happened yeah i'm enjoying it
yeah what does this have to do with you
asking me where
i'm going because i always because
you're from philly and i always
i always hear the fresh prince and i'm
like well i know where i know philly to
be right you know like where i go to
philly the main city yeah like where's
west and is west philadelphia like
nowhere near that is it or the west side
of that city just west of it
i understand but i don't know where that
is i knew you were you knew i was gonna
say that i did i could see on your face
so in the city of philly it's just north
south east west in the proper city so
have i been to west philadelphia or is
it like a suburb like what is i don't
think you've been to westfield no it's
not a suburb it's the city i mean it's
is it is it is is it rough and tumble is
it delightful i don't know if it still
is it was definitely
i we used to go uh when i was younger we
used to go to the overbrook country club
there which was an italian club
uh
which was where the neighborhood
i believe will smith is from uh but west
philadelphia used to be used to be
pretty
you know pretty rough it wasn't the
worst in the filling of the philly
neighborhoods north philly was always
the roughest of the philly neighborhoods
i believe okay
but west philly it's got west philly
blocks struggling with drugs gun
violence where six-year-old was shot
jesus christ
yeah what year is that last year
so i mean it's so it's still it's still
like uh it's still they're still trying
to you know it's from i mean south
philly is rough too that's where beanie
siegel's from i think so so north west
and south philly so east philly
northeast isn't too bad i don't think
philly's a rough-and-tumble town man
what's near camden
camden is in jersey right right but
isn't it on the right on the border
online affiliate and is it known to be
like was that one of the most
rough towns camden i think it was the
wasn't it like the murder capital like
along with like i believe so camden is
tough there's like three three or four
cities that were like really really
tough and i thought canada was one of
them camden's a rough town you live in a
suburb
like when you were in jail in the
suburbs
and then we moved to the suburbs when i
was younger
but where i grew up collegeville is is
it's a it's a you know
at the time was a quaint uh
you know sort of farmland suburb but it
was considered a suburb of philadelphia
it was how it was referred okay but it's
not so when you say i'm from philly i
grew up in philly okay i'm just i was
born there all right well it's ketchup
versus mustard today baby
i mean that what a dry conversation we
just said about filming i know there was
nothing there was nothing there because
we let in because of pretzels yeah you
led in because of pretzels and i had
some questions about west philadelphia
because of will william smith
you never asked one question about west
philly oh wait yes you did you asked
where is it
well i asked where is it and is it is it
is it a tough neighborhood or not i was
it looking for
little education it was i don't know if
it still is but it definitely was yeah
my friends lived in west philly and they
got you liking it to a neighborhood here
uh is it like a bed stuy
yeah it's like you know bushwick
something like that yeah well not not i
mean it sounds like bushwick now but
like i remember my friend kevin got beat
up by a pack of 15 year olds on the
street they jumped him
my other friends lived in west philly
these guys kicked their door in and came
in and pistol-whipped everybody and
robbed them
you know yeah [ __ ] happens out there
that wasn't the first thing that came to
mind when i asked you can you give me a
little litmus test on it's a rough
neighborhood i don't know if it still is
you wait 10 minutes we talk about the
doldrums of it and then you tell me the
pistol whipping toward the end
i gotta tell you something sal
when you're from the streets you don't
talk about the streets
the game is to be sold not to be told
well
all right so our listeners
they're you know what they do right now
during this time
they're always trying to yes guess who's
taking what yeah so go ahead guess
guess who's taking you're done guessing
you're done guessing all right you're
done guessing
they know who's taking what in this i
feel like they do know they know who's
taking the briny salty i'll tell you
who's not gonna i'll tell you who's not
gonna cut the mustard on this episode
i am proudly team mustard on this
episode and i'm team ketchup now now i
also feel like we need to weigh
ready yeah so we need to start off the
debates please
[Laughter]
again like that battle buds
oh my god it's almost like battle bots
yeah we need to start having like a
little more tent police and you think
that me and you should act like teen
cheerleaders i think it's a good way to
i think it's a fun thing to do okay so
you want to start the show off by going
t-a-s-t-e but nope to pause
t-a-s-t-e they spell right t-a-s-t-e
buds okay yeah now we go time to start
the battle
b-a-t-t-l-e buds that one you don't
pause you just hit it i'm sorry
when did you write these rules
i don't know okay she's coming up so
test me again
top of the show top of the show let's
start the show sal welcome to hey taste
buddies welcome to tea
hey i think you're gonna say i'm joe
derosa okay
hey taste buddies welcome to t-a-s-t-e
butts
oh my fun
i will tell you something it's terrible
but if you're doing it it's fun
it's like one of those little whistles
that go
right now
yeah all right it's time for the it's
time for the debate
b-a-t-t-l-e butts
this is terrible what fun is that it is
so fun though yeah all right
i'm pro this oh really
it's corn cent but it's also super fun
let's see how many weeks it takes for
the fans to get pip likes it i think
it's good if pip likes it okay
pips pimp knows his potties i think he
knows you know uh here's the thing
mustard
i am a fan now
muster was one of the couple dozen foods
i didn't get to le into the late and
light life until about maybe a decade
ago or so
catch up i've been i've been at day one
stan
i want you to do me a favor
i want you to start this debate by
keeping my name out your mouth and start
defending your thing make me a catch-up
pitch
make me a ketchup pitch okay instead of
tell me what you don't like about
mustard tell me what you love about
ketchup and why you think it's gonna
take this win okay uh you're starting
from a young age i think that ketchup is
a more amenable taste than mustard is i
think that you'll find
i think that that be a
some a general thing that i can say that
i feel confident in that as as as
children when we're growing up it takes
a little bit more of a defined palate to
get into mustard i think mustard is a
little bit more
sophisticated advanced i don't know if
it's sophisticated so much as it's way
it's at least way more distinct
of a taste this podcast is sponsored by
better help thanks a lot better help we
love you we love what you do
folks if there's something interfering
with your happiness or maybe preventing
you from achieving goals we all get
there something to be ashamed of
something to be embarrassed about but
betterhelp is here to help
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 48 hours none of
the rigomarole that you have to go
through using the health care system
which can be quite laborious
and frustrating quite frankly especially
when you're looking for mental
refreshing there is a broad range of
expertise available which may or may not
be
they're available locally in all areas
there is a broad range of expertise
available which may not be available
locally right in all areas yeah but you
know you got a nice variety here at your
fingertips we want you to visit
betterhelp.com taste buds that's better
help and join the over 1 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with the health of an experienced
professional
that special offer for taste buds
listeners is you get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
taste buds
folks we're here to talk to you about
butcher box today and they've been a
sponsor of the podcast for quite some
time we love them uh i get nine to 11
pounds of meat sent to my house all the
time you could pick
a custom box or they have four preset
boxes that you can take they send you
wild caught lobster tails wild caught
alaskan salmon sugar-free nitrate bacon
free-range organic chicken humanely
raised pork 100 grass-fed and finished
beef it's just taking the supermarket
out of it it's taking everything out of
it you could be fully stocked all the
time uh of course we have a great offer
here today's sponsor butcher box wants
to give you something amazing so right
now they're offering our members
free ground beef for life
i
i wow they took my breath away with that
one that's a big sentence that's two
pounds of ground beef in every box for
the life of your subscription for free
you used to have to win a game show to
get a deal like that yeah that's insane
um
i i use butcher box i you know they we
tried them out they sent some stuff to
my house i went through all the meets i
ordered it again i personally use it and
i love it um you just sign up you choose
your delivery frequency uh like i said
they offer five different boxes
including custom box uh they're frozen
at their peak freshness and they're
shipped in eco-friendly packaging so you
know every everybody is world and uh
conscious of of the globe today so
everything's eco-friendly and that's it
it's right to you and it's free shipping
yeah so go get this deal two pounds of
ground beef for life uh for the life of
your subscription obviously if you stop
subscribing they don't just keep sending
you
they're not they're not that nice
butcherbox.com
taste buds is where you're gonna get
that deal that's butcherbox.com
taste buds
i think that mustard ketchup can be
applied uh
to many more things especially foods
that children eat
your hamburgers your hot dogs your
chicken fingers your eggs your mashed
potatoes like things like that and i
think that they get acclimated to
ketchup way earlier i think that the the
ketchup tastes from tomato i think that
kids taste tomato and a lot of other
things the first time i tasted mustard i
thought it was super foreign and super
potent and
i i recoiled a little bit from it and
then i had that in my head about mustard
for life until i got old enough to
appreciate mustard but it is like a more
sour
spicy
tangy i'll say this
i have liked mustard since i was a child
that checks out for me
you would be a child that likes monsters
sound off in the comments actually if
you have children um what are their
takes what are their ages and their
takes on on ketchup and mustard my my
gut tells me that a lot of kids uh
aren't down with mustard from a young
age no you got a big variety though i i
but that i like mustard from a young age
why
ham and cheese sandwich mustard mayo i
put on that no i was i mustard couldn't
look i'm not saying i never put mayo on
it i'm just saying mustard hot dog
always put mustard and ketchup on it
together mcdonald's cheeseburgers ate
them since i was little they had mustard
on them i love mustard i think mustard
is the all-time greatest condiment that
has ever existed wow when it comes to
variety when it comes to versatility
when it comes to cooking and recipes
mustard is king
nothing can touch it
first of all with ketchup
all cold cuts are off the table with
ketchup
true you're making a cold sandwich
you you mustard is your is your boy dude
with a cold sandwich
not saying mayo is here's what i found
and and let me know if you agree with me
uh dear listener um i found that like a
lot of times i gotta be if you if i want
mustard on my sandwich i better be in
the mood for mustard because i think
mustard just dominates the sandwich so a
lot of times if i make a ham and cheese
these days and i put mustard on it i
really really really
am like all right you're going to be
eating basically a mustard sandwich with
ham and cheese on it whereas i feel like
if i put mayo on it
you taste mayo but i think mayo has a
way of combining with the bread the ham
and the cheese to make a taste profile
together whereas when i put on mustard i
feel like i'm eating ham and cheese and
mustard does that make sense it does
make sense i understand that it's a that
there's a shoe becomes mustard dominant
well it feels like everything else takes
a back seat to mustard i wouldn't say
that i think i i understand that it's
three distinct flavors
and that mayo is more cohesive with the
bread but i will say this too
nothing and we're not here to talk mayo
but we will for a second nothing grosses
me out more than too much mayo on a
sandwich
it's disgusting i agree too much mustard
i could deal with too much ketchup i
could deal with okay too much mustard i
can deal with too much ketchup i could
deal with too much mayo couldn't agree
more it's so disgusting now i'll tell
you this here's another one here's
another plus for mustard okay
we almost did mayo mustard
we always did it mayo is so polarizing
might have been a close-up match-up
because i do think ketchup's the
favorite but ketchup i do i think you're
i think you're gonna win just out of the
the sheer popularity of ketchup yeah you
got to be honest i hate to say it it
burns my ass yeah but there's more
applications baby but here's you take
out cold cuts but please continue well
well here's the thing catch up
you got hinds and then it's game over
that's it i disagree heinz ketchup which
i told you before we started scientists
tested it and said it was the most
perfectly flavor balanced food on earth
perfect amount of sweet salty everything
perfect flavor profile is heinz ketchup
you give me any ketchup that isn't hind
you can take a walk dude i'm not
interested at all heinz has ketchup on
lockdown as as as far as popularity of
ketchup goes you know you got your hunts
you got your homemades you got your
store brands like i have a trader joe's
black truffle says ketchup which is nice
but can i tell you about a ketchup that
has entered the market recently for me
actually a brand that has entered the
condiment market on the whole that has
really shook things up for me right sir
kensingtons you know i see this sir
kensington flaunting himself walking
around he's a market disrupter babe his
ketchup is it's different it doesn't
taste as processed it just tastes
something it's something about is more
natural and organic but flavorful and
really really like high quality that's
not what i'm looking for i'm not looking
for that i'm looking for a heinz ketchup
but let me tell you this sir kensington
people if you're watching and we know
that you are
please
send me a whole bunch of free [ __ ]
listen i'll try your ketchup i i'll try
it and if i'm if i stand corrected i
stay corrected the product line has ever
expanded i'm gonna tell you right now i
don't like his attitude at all i don't
like the missing he seems like he's
looking at me yeah he looks like the guy
from monopoly i mean i don't need to see
that guy staring at me as i eat my
burger you know what i mean it's gonna
piss me off all right but i think that
hines i think right hunts has been
around hunter has a purpose i don't
think huntington's not good though
well the nice people are hunts it's not
for me uh
i do think sir kensington is a sponsor
you know
no but people work there no i get it i i
don't like it if you eat hunts next time
look if you guys i like heinz more than
hunts yeah but i'm telling the
circumstances and if i get we should do
a blind taste test oh
we should have had a blind taste test
ready for today downstairs
i have sir kensingtons probably but i
don't have the other two
that would have been delightful we could
have done another episode let me just go
get the sir kenza let me just taste it
you've had sir kensington you just
commented on it no i never had it oh i
thought you why would you say it's not
you just don't like the look of it said
hunts is not good okay i said sir
kensington i'm not looking at i'm not
looking for this i'm not looking for
natural flavor
he's got an attitude problem why don't
you get go get a spoon full of sir
kensington let me taste it well i will
let's let's go let's just go into this i
also want to talk about the 57 with
heinz heinz company by the way
heinz
for me though sir kensington is new it's
great and everything like that but heinz
for me has been the staple of my family
and i also just want to say to the
lovely people of heinz thank you for
sponsoring my team to pittsburgh
steelers and heinz fields lovely field
i'm going to tell you this before you go
history before you go history
hines yellow mustard great i'm just
talking yellow mustard for a second yeah
yellow mustard wrenches what honey
yellow mustard great then if you start
getting into the browns dude french's
heinz and then you're getting into uh
dijon gray poupon i mean my god great
mighty dude
french there are three
grand slam hitters right off the bat do
people even know who grape upon is
anymore because that that was an ad
campaign when we were young i bet you
you don't know who great poupon is no no
i know you do
yeah it was like marketed as fancy pants
yeah
yeah
how do you know that because they don't
do that anymore i listen to a lot of
radio uh who's the original sir
kensington pass the great poupon
right and then i said would you please
pass the grape on and then one guy goes
will you please pass the jelly yeah can
you pull that up yeah i mean just just
oh goldens you didn't even talk about
golden's yet goldens i forgot goldens
goldens goldens yeah you got bangers out
there then dude you ever have nathan's
hot dog mustard no
it's amazing
it's amazing the mustard the mustard
companies there's a good variety of them
you got a lot of heavy hitters out there
but i mean heinz is like the is it's
just like the the empire i mean what i'm
saying you know
it's a dijon mustard standalone that
came out we were younger and it marketed
itself the guy the way they they market
it is the guy is in the back of a
chauffeur rolls-royce
but of course
and then he doesn't share it all right
pause this because this commercial is
batshit
okay first of all who are they marketing
to i get that they want to stamp home
that grey boupon is an uppity like up
high-end mustard which by the way
it's just sold in every super national
tell you who they're marketing it to who
they're marketing to
garbage people that don't know what
fancy things are and we'll see this
commercial and think that they're fancy
because they bought great pout that's
really what it is this [ __ ] aired during
like after school
the guy that goes can you please pass
the jelly yeah because that's another
one so this is
the commercial is a an old gray-haired
white-haired
man that looks like wealthy like he
lives in a castle pulls up in a
rolls-royce being chauffeured he has a
tray he's eating his lunch in the back
he applies great poupon another
rolls-royce pulls up next to him being
chauffeured another old white wealthy
man lowers and asks if he has grey
poupon the guy says of course but then
pulls away and doesn't even share it
with them yeah like like like how like
now the pull away without the share is
that how dare you ask for any of my
precious commodity or is that your trash
if you don't have your own i think it's
everything under the sun
you know what i mean it's like of course
i have it you don't i'm better than you
okay of course i haven't you don't you
think i'm sharing mine i love it too
much of course i have it i'm wealthy
enough to have it you don't have it
you're suspect it's the whitest
commercial that has ever existed it is
and then the audacity with the jelly guy
which was not in that one
they're just throwing him at this one
okay hold on let's watch this one here's
the one we need to see
oh it's all for a week that's right
poland are all for a pause
we just confused it's the same exact
marketing campaign yeah are they not the
same people i don't know grape
polanar polanar all fruit which is jelly
they wanted to be a high-end jelly we
just that's where my mind went they were
so similar in ad campaigns i combined
both of them that's wild i not even
noticed it i didn't i did too when you
said it i was like oh yeah i remember
that commercial keeps
in effect
helping men keep what they got up on the
dome a lot of guys by the time they are
35 experience some form of hair loss i'm
talking two out of three men can i show
you something can you feel this right
here i don't want to okay well i feel
like i might have a little bit of
thinning going on right here really yeah
and so it keeps in the past wasn't
necessarily for me i think i might try
it now really yeah now are you just
saying this because of the keeps
brochures i've been planting discreetly
around your
i know how to take a hint yeah yeah yeah
yeah no but i have friends that use it
more about more than 50 million men this
is a stat they tell us in the u.s suffer
from male pattern baldness and they're
only two fda approved medications that
can prevent hair loss keeps offers both
of them they've got convenient virtual
doctor consultations and the medications
are delivered straight to your door
every three months you don't have to
leave home this is all about prevention
you see it starting and you stop it in
its tracks
with the help of keeps treatments can
take four to six months to see results
though so act fast
packaging proven results low cost
treatments are just 10 bucks a month
they start at and keeps offers generic
versions so it's not going to break the
bank go to keeps.com that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash taste buds k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash taste buds you're gonna get
your first month of treatment for free
that's
keps.com taste buds to get your first
month free
i got a bod you got a bod but we would
like to have a fit box
fitbot is an app that sponsored the show
and i like it because you can customize
your workout to whatever you have in the
house to your level of expertise uh to
your level i mean i'm not a guy i'm not
a gym rat myself i actually don't even
have um equipment but if i did you can
tailor fitbot to what equipment you have
i don't i do the workouts that aren't uh
equipment based yeah i agree but yeah
i'm not a gym rat either i'm a rat yeah
i've ran it on friends and all kinds of
people but i'm not a gym rat which is
the only kind of good rat i believe
yeah yeah i guess you're right it is the
only good around i don't know i mean
i've gone on like diets of four and i
plateau yeah and you need to mix in
exercise with your dieting to break
through those plateaus and go further uh
you know i i've i've leveled out and and
i found that when i add something like a
regiment that i could follow to it i see
results i always so i hear you babe and
i'm looking up videos like this on
youtube anyway half the time when i'm
trying to you know what i mean it's all
there it's all searchable it's all easy
to use great
yeah i don't have to save it to a
playlist anymore where it's like a
workout video then a review of the last
jedi
is it a recipe well of course we have
an offer for our listeners pick up the
pace on your fitness journey with fitpod
today and your future self will thank
you get 25 off your membership at
fitbot.me that's fitbot.me
slash tastebuds that's 25 off at
fitpod.me tastebuds check it out let us
know what you think
yeah so this one it's a wealthy white
family at a fine dining restaurant and
the matriarchy of the family asks for
poland
by the way in the grey poupon i don't
think you said this in the grey poupon
ad
what the man is using it for what he's
eating
is a full
i didn't see it it's like
it's like a roast beef dinner or
something
he's like cutting meat with a diamond
fork and putting down like a steak dip
could you imagine this is why i know
they were they were they were
advertising towards people that couldn't
afford a fancy restaurant but wanted to
feel fancy at the supermarket if you
ever
went into a steak like a high-end steak
place and said could i have some mustard
please
they would throw you out yeah use your
head to open the door
out just like if you ever went into like
a fancy schmance like french restaurant
like this is supposed to be and you said
do you have any jelly
that's amazing
let this let's let this one play
it's so nuts dude
yeah go ahead that are all fruit
pass the poland
would you please pass it jelly
polaner all fruit is real fruit
sweetened only with fruit juice you'll
call it delicious you'll call it
remarkable but please don't and then a
rich aristocrat lady faints
because she's so offended that this
redneck who's at the table with her in a
suit
why is he there there's only five people
at the table she knows nothing of this
man that he he
he's in a suit with her and asked but
he's pious the jelly and then she's in a
combination she's just five rows of
pearls on can you imagine can you
imagine
the balls on this company that they're
like our ad campaign is we're just going
to take a dump on the south right that's
what we're going to do i mean that was
like i mean what you please pious yeah
we'll drown oh insane yeah do you think
they're playing with beverly hillbillies
was that oh
okay could be no but she was like
think about those people in that in the
in the um
in the freaking uh uh marketing
in that in that conference room that'll
just like all right here's the most you
want to get relatable let's get [ __ ]
relatable
i mean it's it and she's been sitting 90
year old white men that are definitely
like oil tycoons
eating steak with mustard on the back of
their rolls voices
she's sitting with
she's sitting with him
and she faints from the shock that he is
not as sophisticated as she is that oh
my god i've been sharing my table with
this philistine yeah who thinks this is
jelly which by the way
it is damn jelly it's straight jelly
jelly she was like she passed out at the
fact that he couldn't discern
that spreadable fruit with real fruit
juice had any difference from the thing
that's most closely related to which is
jelly she was so appalled
that he could not make the distinction
between an incredible all fruit and
jelly that she lost oxygen to her brain
right right and she faded in a public
setting and then the waiter in a in a it
comes out and he's fanning her down and
hopes to revise fanning her down with a
silver platter
using a fan and the girl is a young girl
who seems well adjusted for someone
being raised around these types right
and she giggles that i think she's the
daughter of the trash oh do you can you
can you wind that back is she the
trash's daughter she's the treacherous
this guy the other guy at the table it's
like they don't even know each other
they got seated there a la carte the
other guy at the table is appalled and
disgusted i do think it's like there's
this is a commentary on like in high
society we intermingle with other you
know what i mean like
this is it's crazy yeah but effective
i mean look off the top of our heads we
rattled off both ad campaigns and
they're so similar i connected that and
i got to tell you the great poupon
commercial made me want to do nothing
more than spread grey poupon on sliced
turkey
on my platter whatever the hell he was
eating people looked really good the
people at poland are in great poupon why
don't you why don't you make an updated
version of this and to tell you some
some some wealthy
some wealthy uh uh dot-com guy goes
through a less fortunate neighbor this
is what you're doing right here anyway
we know
do we have any connection to i mean we
look we made connections with peanut
butter company right do we have any
connection to a mustard company do you
think somebody does anybody out there
make
mustard for your company and will you
make a taste buds
special brand called you trash
and it's a it's a dijon mustard
taste must presents you trash
[Music]
first of all let's stop masquerading
high fructose let's stop masquerading
jelly and mustard as anything high end
it's ground seeds and a bunch of sugar
and fruit i'll tell you i'm a heavy
grape user i'm a heavy grape i love it
we got to get into this battle it's my
we're in the battle we're doing it i
know but we're really just talking about
great people i love i love grey poupon
i'll tell you what though
you've fallen from grace grey poupon
cause you got your stuff in a squirt
bottle now like no they don't yeah how
dare they slid down the square now the
jars might still exist i don't know
because i only ever buy it in square
bottle now because i'm like this is
great i can squirt it on my sandwich
yeah well so in in a restaurant i used
to work at we used to keep the the uh
the glass heinz jars and then after they
were done we'd wash them
dry them and then take get big cans of
heinz ketchup and then fill them back up
so we're not over in glass bottles all
the time but the glass bottle i think is
a really beautiful touch to a ketchup i
don't know if hunts does a glass bottle
kensington doesn't uh plastic's ruining
the earth i love the i like hitting that
57 and waiting for it to come out i
remember heinz is a very effective ad
campaign where it just and it doesn't it
doesn't come out of that bottle unless
you get a knife and jab it up there or
you really really wait remember that
they used to turn the hinds over and
just wait and then finally hit the
burger underneath so like it's worth it
or whatever yeah i just think that uh i
don't know i think it's it's neck that's
how you get it out hit that 57 which 57
varieties what was that 57 in hinds uh i
i read it after this day nobody knows is
that was it a secret i don't know
there's i always hear crazy like
different stories i i've yet to confirm
any of them
there was heinz 57 sauce too no i
thought it was very straightforward what
it was yeah 57 varieties yeah
heinz 57 sauce which i felt for heinz
was a rare misstep
you know what the heinz so then they
went into the plastic bottle right now
they got the plastic bottle mustard
doesn't do that stands the cap down so
it's all at the bottom of the bottle but
then they started
i mean have you ever seen a more genius
invention revolutionized
if they did it or shampoo did it first
whoever came up with that is correct
yeah and then what they did was they
started making the bottle red
so that you never because you know so it
looks a little bit more appealing it
always looks full it always looks fully
representative of a fresh spot i told
you i knew where to get glass bottles of
heinz
what would you say
real do they do they not do that anymore
they don't have them in the stores they
don't oh are you positive i have not
seen one remember when we were little
two there was a small one yeah then the
bigger one and then the big one do you
know what i like though i like ordering
room service and getting a little mini
bottle that's that's fun yeah that's
that's funny i feel like i told you i
had a line on some glass bottles of fine
i would love that all right let me see
what i can do i think
hind has actually become like pop art i
might be surprised if if uh warhol did
didn't warhol mess with heinz i know he
did campbell's i want to give you a
little history of uh
no he did campbell's i i i don't think
he did but you know ketchup is
ketchup can be put on everything dude
except for cold cuts ketchup is hot dogs
it's hamburgers it's fried chicken
uh fried chicken chicken
of all kinds of
dudes
babe honey mustard what are we talking
about this is the most potato of all
chicken finger sauces is honey mustard
that is the one dude
yeah
dude it's look go back to the honey
mustard is new to the to it's new to the
chat really i remember honey mustard
coming on strong in in about when i was
in college go back to the history
i do love a good honey mustard
okay hold on prepared mustard as we know
it began in dijon france did you know
there was a place called dijon
was made in like tallahassee it would be
called tallahassee mustard
i thought dijon was a flavor
that's what i thought too uh made in the
13th century encouraged by the mustard
loving pope
john the 22nd of avignon who created the
position of grand muster deer do pop to
pepe
or grand mustard maker he the pope had a
grand
mustard maker wow that is insane who
lived near dijon and made him mustard
how is this not a movie you know they
make these biopics they make these
biopics about stuff you don't give a
[ __ ] about they made the one about the
guy who invented windshield wipers they
made the one about the lady who made the
mops
how
not
the
frig
mustard maker biopic i know whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa what are those
things right there from the most
disgusting things i've ever cranch
what's cranch so you didn't you don't
remember this
i sent you a picture of these
and i said these every name of one of
these it was like in the very it was in
the early stages of our friendship and i
sent you a picture of these i said every
name of these is more disgusting than
the last mayo must oh my god yeah heinz
i love you male must i get it gets the
point of christ names are so great
must a musty thing like mustard is good
but when you cut mustard down to must
must doesn't ring appealing ranch is the
grossest what's crunch it's ketchup and
ranch sauce oh my god mayoque
oh mayo and barbecue it's just i get it
but some of the parts some of the parts
sometimes just doesn't do it for me you
have no recollection of me sending you
that do you no not one of those three
flavors at least i think it was you sent
me something and it was gross i think it
was well let me say i haven't tasted
these things but the idea of them i i
don't like i don't like a mixture of
look that's like peanut butter and jelly
in the same jar it's like let me i'll
mix my own sauces thank you you know
when that came out though as a kid i had
no balls
with no context it sounds like i'm a
freaking eunuch no when i when i blew my
balls off when they when they mixed the
jelly in the peanut butter one thing
i was like this makes so much sense it
is more convenient it's fun i want to
stick to my hand my foreground i want to
swear i was disgusting to this day by
day one i was just something about
already i love peanut butter in a jar
because it's like so smooth and i love
breaking the seal on top but when you
have the peanut butter and the jelly in
there they still sell that yeah listen i
think so now here's the thing would i
eat it now yeah i'd eat it now and i eat
it with a spoon as like a fun treat
what disgusted me as a kid i would never
buy it though as my peanut butter and
jelly sauce because the same thing
that this is a kid which was once you
did it once putting that thing back and
taking it out again and looking inside
that second round well you couldn't mix
it then it would look like a slop oh so
you just have to get what i don't like
about it is it doesn't allow me to
choose how much jelly or mustard i
really kind of want on my sandwich um
jelly or peanut butter give us a little
catch to catch up history because we got
to go to the phone yeah we gotta go to
the phones this was a mellow up today it
was but can i just continue though but
that's okay eggs
yeah ketchup potatoes
ketchup
okay
chicken fried or other
mustard on potatoes too but go ahead do
you ever see sling blade
french fried
potatoes but they go on mustard oh they
do
or eats his biscuits with mustard eat
something eats mustard mustard came into
my life strictly with the pretzel and
then i transform it but i will i don't
know man i just think ketchup when i
bite into like a beautiful like
cheeseburger with ketchup on it i don't
feel like i'm eating a ketchup sandwich
you know i think it does what mayo does
in a way that it combines with the meat
the cheese and the bread to accentuate
the taste
and bring it to new heights when i eat
mustard i feel like i'm just eating
mustard dominating if you're
putting but if you're putting the amount
of ketchup
if you're putting the amount of mustard
that you would put on a burp
what the hell am i trying to say if you
put the same amount of mustard in a
burger that you do ketchup you're doing
the mustard wrong mustard should i've
never eaten mustard on a burger oh dude
it's on every mcdonald's burger i asked
him to take it off oh no you're nuts you
know what i don't like about mustard too
when you open it and all that like
discharge comes out yeah
that's a bummer i agree that's a bummer
it's like coagulated and oily and
my favorite dipping sauce of all time is
mcdonald's hot mustard the hot mustard
dipping sauce is king of all dipping
sauces who would have known you would
have brought it up you know
uh and you want to talk about things you
can put mustard on i mean dude you can
make you know how many recipes i do with
like dijon mustard as a base and you'd
bake chicken in it and it's delicious
dude
mustard and white wine recipes uh you
putting mustard on your your your
sandwiches as we already said um
it does it does go with chicken it's uh
there's like there's like recipes for
like mustard-based uh rib sauces
mustard-based barbecue sauces
they're all
it's got a lot of yeah but you got to
ask yourself why has mustard not
achieved the heights of ketchup look at
this
mustard is the clear winner it says in
the health department brings a myriad of
ailments relief for ailments oh
ketchup's really bad for your health
boys that's right
even poor respiratory sugar it's hot
it's corn it's it's bad it heals now
this is the clawhound pole ketchup
versus mustard who won this pimp we were
unaware of this
it'll tell you at the bottom the winner
well i mean it's it's undoubtedly that
mustard is better than ketchup for you
it has no sugar
it's like three ingredients and that's
the other thing too sal you want to talk
here you look at the back of a mustard
bottle it's like three four ingredients
you'll get the back of a ketchup bottle
and i hate to say cause i love heinz
you're seeing a lot of hydro
silio whatever
options that catch about they suck
brother it sounds like you open it
tastes like you open a can of tomato
paste and you know it and i know it i've
never put ketchup on something
and
wasn't happy with it because i put the
ketchup on no no no no that's not what
i've never been like this is too much
ketchup or like i'm saying health-wise
no no i gotcha i got you i'm just just
just jumping around and i put stuff up
mustard on stuff and be like i wish i
didn't put the mustard on it i want you
i'm going to go to the phones i want you
to go downstairs please
and bring me a space i hope i have some
kensington yeah all right i usually do
but i might be out of it because i used
it so much okay
what do you really want me to do this
right now yeah okay let me go there for
the episode pimp take me to the phones
i'll read a couple comments while sal
goes down
ketchup is the participation trophy of
condiments nice in theory but other than
a few exceptions mostly suited for small
children good point mustard is right
next to ron jeremy's baby gravy
on the list of things i want least on my
food liquefied dick cheese in a bottle
jesus that might be our winner right out
of the gate jesus god
ketchup through time has stood alone is
wait ketchup through time has stood
alone
in greatness i think that's supposed to
read while mustard needs honey spicy and
dijon to stay relevant that's not true i
hate both
all right here we go
you have to bring all the mustards up
all right
wow
can i show you something here
nutrition facts
tomatoes tomato paste fair trade organic
cane sugar
water
onions distilled vinegar salt lime juice
green bell peppers all spices okay those
are the ingredients okay these are kind
of not a single
chemical but you got sugar in there
yeah
ingredients i understand
i understand i understand mustard
ingredients water mustard seeds
distilled vinegar white wine boom okay
out the door
water mustard distilled vinegar salt
i've had this dijon
this is trader joe's dijon i love it i
don't need to taste it i love it
this is i'm not a fan of whole grain
mustard i don't like the
it's got a weird aftertaste to me i've
never liked whole grain but let's see
this sir kensington to see if i can get
a healthy ketchup into my life
what you're not gonna have it on
anything so what you don't think i can
tell if it's good or
oh
not
oh my god oh it's good right you know to
be good on meatloaf
meatloaf is another thing people will
catch up on i put mustard on mine too no
you don't i put ketchup and mustard on
it really i've never heard of that
is that not that lights out
it's really good sir kensington i i
apologize sir
non-gmo
i apologize sir i spoke out of line
is classic ketchup your main squeeze
have a fling with our spicy brown
mustard
all right well sir kensington if you're
watching and we imagine that you are
please send me all your products back to
the phones
the germans didn't use ketchup gas is
all i'm saying oh my god
that's the winner sweet nobody's gonna
beat that nobody's gonna be so you're
saying mustard is better
no yes he is worse no he's saying
ketchup is better he's saying mustard's
evil oh okay
that does all depends depends who that
person is jordan cup for the win follow
jordan at
j.o.r
jesus i can't talk today at
j-o-r-d-a-n-c-u-p-p
c-u-p-p
no oh wow really
uh
wow 16 500 votes is that on a refresh
too
yeah
uh did you read enough
yeah we did yeah all right let's do it
let's go to this segment of humble pie
see who is going to win this thing
h-u-m-l-e
pie
[Laughter]
oh boy oh boy the question is how big
of a victory is it catch up
handily
well i would believe that believe that
come on seventy three point one percent
catch up to twenty six point nine
percent
off that's it rubbing it's
that is three times it's three to one
three to one
i would guess i would have guessed that
how would you not guess that i would
guess three to one people prefer ketchup
over mustard
26 to 20. you need it more often you
apply it to more monsters the king of
all condiments says who me right yeah so
does your mustard isle go into the
mustard aisle there's tons of mustard
but people are reaching for ketchup more
than they than they're reaching for
mustard i would be surprised i wouldn't
i wonder where mayo would finish against
mustard and i wonder where mayo would
finish against ketchup
well that'd be a good one to bring in
for a guest we'll have a guest come in
and we'll see how mayo does we could do
like a four-way i think we revisit
yeah i don't know
oh here's one thing that we want to be
we want to try and i'll say this
we'll get out right away we want to
start doing these things where we do
lightning episodes so there's some
matchups that we really like that we
don't do because we don't know if they'd
sustain a whole episode for example
tootsie pop versus blow pop right
something like that and we're like how
do we get we have a whole bunch of those
like how do we get those in so now we're
thinking we'll do like things called
lightning episodes where there's three
smaller once in a while there's three
smaller
matchups in a single episode we battle
quickly
and then that episode still each battle
each poll counts toward the record so
you come out with three and oh and one
from one episode or one and three or two
in one or any combination of three yeah
we'll have many do so we might be doing
that maybe we'll do it next maybe we'll
do it in the next couple of episodes and
some of those suggestions come from fans
too we're like yeah that's cool but it's
not a full episode yeah but uh so that's
next stay tuned
i still love you man still love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds